الان الى هذا الفيديو الذي وصلنا وننقلها
لكم من سجن كوبر هذا السجن شديد الحراسه
بالخرطوم ونتابع احد المساجين وهو يحاول
فك القيود وفك هذه الاصفاد محاوله للفرار
طبعا كثر الحديث في الاونه الاخيره عن هذا
السجن وعن الموقوفين في سجن كوبر الذين
فروا حيث تكررت الهجمات ثانيه على هذا
السجن الشهير طبعا في العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم وطبعا نذكر بانه يضم ما ابرز
القاده السابقين في نظام عمر بشير ومن
ضمنهم ايضا الرئيس المعزول نفسه واحد اهم
اثنين من مستشاريه ومعاونيه نستمع الان
الى صوت الطبيعي ومن ثم نعود
رئيس
[موسيقى]
جريمه فرصه
يعني
[موسيقى]
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات